an Oklahoma man is in federal custody
this morning accused of plotting a bomb
attack on American soil
authorities say 23 year-old Jerry Drake
Vernell tried to blow up what he thought
was a vehicle bomb at a bank in Oklahoma
City it is just blocks from the site of
the 1995 bombing that killed 168 people
at the Alfred P murrah Federal Building
Omar Villafranca is at the Oklahoma City
National Memorial Museum
Omar good morning good morning federal
officials say varnel was upset with the
government and planned to use a device
similar to the one used in the domestic
terror attack here more than 20 years
ago according to court documents a
confidential informant alerted the FBI
to Parnell's alleged plan the informant
then introduced varnel to an undercover
FBI agent posing as someone who could
help him get bomb-making supplies and
planned the attack varnel then helped
assemble what he thought was a 1,000
pound bomb made from ammonium nitrate he
was arrested overnight Saturday when he
tried to detonate it at the bank first
building in downtown Oklahoma City
varnel reportedly had mental health
issues on his Facebook page Cade varnel
a user claiming to be the suspects
brother posted this comment my brother
is schizophrenic and the FBI brought him
the van loaded with explosives good job
America but federal officials say they
gave varnel multiple chances to pull out
of the attack if convicted he could face
up to 20 years in prison
Gale thank you very much Omar